you know everyday you you read a story
about how climate change is getting
worse and worse you're reading a lot of
those stories these days well we all
have to do our part so I'm proud to
announce that the staff here at Conan is
making some changes to help our show
become more eco friendly for example
we're pledging to get rid of all plastic
straws yeah thank you also also every
staffer must plant 30 trees in their
office that's as if yes that is a new
rule 30 trees in the office we're
getting rid of our wasteful single-use
studio cameras will no longer be using
any cups that's the new rule here at the
show here in the studio replacing the
air conditioning with - shirtless hunks
Andy of course will now be solar-powered
it's burning my back our applause sign
will no longer be coal powered good luck
finding a sign that doesn't use coal
[ __ ] wait a minute what are you doing
to be eco-friendly well Andy I do a lot
I mean I think I do enough frankly oh
really
Billy could you show them how Conan gets
from his dressing room to the stage hey
pal hey guys
that's right